been working here for about a year and
I've never even seen Mr mahina well see
that's that's an easy one to answer
that's because he comes in before you
come into work and he's still working
when you leave that's what makes a Mr
mahina you know come on we're talking
about Mr mahina here right it makes
perfect sense you know I bet the
hard-working boss would love to meet a
hard-working employee you know shares
the same values so I'm gonna go ahead
and just introduce myself no no
you can't go into some heinous room are
you crazy no one except me is allowed to
go in there Mr mahina is busy
okay fine you made your point clear man
thank you very much
come on man
what
question my insistence will you